Here is something just genuinely funny.
Uh, we've wondered for a while now whether
Fox news propagandist and friend of Donald
Trump's Sean Hannity was in some way going
to end up implicated in the corruption and
criminality of the Trump administration.
Now, in the midst of the Ukraine fiasco, Hannani's
name is starting to come up more and more
frequently and Hannity absolutely lost it
over this unfortunate reality so far.
Hannity's name has been brought up by two
different people.
First one mentioned by former Ukrainian ambassador
Marie Evanovich or you over.
No bitch, I'm not exactly, I've heard it pronounced
both ways.
And then when state department, deputy assistant
secretary George Kent, who oversees Ukraine,
mentioned Sean Hannity.
And the reason Sean Hannity has been pulled
into all of this is that on his program he
said that a ambassador, you have a Nova, which
had bad mouth, Donald Trump.
Now it's untrue even though it did end up
getting her removed from her position.
Kent under oath said quote, I believe to the
best of my recollection, the counselor for
the department, all Rick Breck Buel reached
out and suggested to Sean Hannity that if
there was no proof of the allegations that
he should stop covering them.
He then you Bonovitch in her own testimony
described being told, uh, that secretary of
state, Mike Pompeo might personally get in
touch with Hannity and tell him to stop saying
these things about her, that they are not
true.
And this causes Hannity to just explode on
Twitter over the weekend, starting with number
one more lies and fake news.
I never ever spoke to secretary, Palm, PEO
or anyone else at the state department about
Ukraine.
I've never even heard the names of the people
mentioned from state.
Also, I never talked to anyone in Ukraine.
I don't know anybody there.
Then going on to tweet that number two, here
is a warning, capital w adopting that, um,
uh, uh, grammatical sensibility of Donald
Trump.
You have all been told the truth.
Again, I strongly advise all of you to stop
lying about me.
Now of course, these aren't lies.
These are reports about testimony given under
oath by multiple people.
They may be inaccurate.
You may say it's not true what Kent and [inaudible]
said under oath, but it is not a lie to report
that this is what was asserted Lizer what
handed he tells on his show all the time.
Now, what's the likely truth about all this?
We know that there was a campaign of character
assassination against the ambassador of Murray
Avanti, which we know Rudy Giuliani seems
to have led that campaign.
We know Rudy Giuliani is Trump's lawyer, or
at least was, I guess now nobody knows whether
they are still in that relationship or not.
And we know that Hannity and Trump speak all
the time.
So let's play our Occam's razor game.
What is more likely that two different people
perjured themselves when they testified under
oath in order to incorrectly say something
about Sean Hannity or that Hannity who talks
to Trump regularly, was simply doing the same
thing Rudy was doing because they all decided
let's go after ambassador Maria Bonovitch.
You be the judge about which requires the
fewest assumptions and if Hannity is claiming
that others are lying under oath, bring in
Sean Hannity, put them under oath, ask the
questions about exactly who told which lies.
Truly his name is coming up way too often
in connection to Donald Trump's corruption
to have no knowledge or Inbar involvement
in any of these efforts.
It's just coming up too frequently and there
is no reason that his name would be coming
up other than he is in some way, shape or
form involved.
In the same way that Rudy Giuliani is wrapped
up in all of this, I would not be even remotely
surprised if Sean Hannity also ended up with
some sketchy role in this entire fiasco and
maybe at some point we will find out.
Let me know what you think the extent of Hannity's
knowledge and involvement in Trump's corruption
and potential criminality is.
Let me know on Twitter at D Pacman or by leaving
a reply as a YouTube comment.
If you are watching on YouTube, we will take
a quick break
and be back with much, much more.
Uh, in just a few very brief moments.